the main challenge it was how we can
scale micro environment that is has is
so highly controlled and it's known for
being useful for example in eleven
achieves on organs on a chip
so really small devices that allow you
to create the conditions to make studies
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm really excited because we
just finished up Indy bio demo day we
didn't get a chance to sit down with a
couple of the company so we are brought
brought them into studio to be able to
explain what they're building and why
it's important with us we have stem stem
bio and we have both shushil and Fred of
Federico joining us the co-founders and
cousins of stem thank you for coming on
to the show I did not know I did not
know that I didn't know when you make
sure you bring the mic up if you're
gonna speak just like now tell me about
this journey because your cousin's you
started a biotech company you're from
Argentina Argentina and so how did this
happen where did what were your careers
that led you up to making this well even
we know each other since we were born
basically but what brought us to start
this company actually was beer and our
grandfather
so our grandfather taught us how to brew
beer when we were really young and we
saw an opportunity on creating a
business out of selling beer and we
started working with by starting to
offer our product we saw that there was
also a backin see on the providers of
yeast for Brewers so I was studying
agriculture engineer at the University
at the moment and focusing on bio
processing
by manufacturing so I saw opportunity of
us being the ones that were that'd be
like that yeast right so we started the
company as these manufacturers for
Brewers in Argentina and we will we
design facility that to do that leased
and we soon found out that it was really
expensive to do so and even though we
know how to brew use for the last 100
years there was no one in our country I
was doing so and it wasn't because they
didn't knew how to brew East but they
didn't have access to the tools and that
would cause that we didn't have any
supplier for that work specifically so
we focus on trying to solve our problem
by making linear infrastructure for
doing biotech and that was the first
pilot that we got we build a small
biotech facility to offer yeast for
Brewers but even when we did that we
shrink the cost of that facility by 50 X
Y Wow 50 yes
shrinking the manufacturing footprint of
your facility for yeast yes and reducing
the traditional team and making more a
dynamic to production so you can offer
different kind of strains I work with a
more a costume customizable orders for
clients yes but even when we got there
we saw there was this constraint
regarding scaling of that kind of
approaches and also gathering the team
that it was necessary so it's a really
delicate process and if someone make a
mistake by day five they were ruined a
week worth of work of the whole team so
once again a at that time we got a
little more of recognition from the
ecosystem and we start to being reach
out by other industries saying that they
have the same problem so at that point
we are interesting applications that are
not easy
yes exactly that is what we're actually
you know things started become very
interesting because it opened a new
world of possibilities for us it's like
when you find the pain
you know we were told many many times to
find a pain and then you have a business
it's like we found a very very big pain
because we're going through this
Renaissance of biotech right and many
many startups what is happening right
now they have this brilliant ideas that
they come up with but they find out very
quickly that the strains that they are
developing they you know sales behave in
one way when when you are in the lab in
a very very small scale but when you
take those cells to a beat bioreactor
well things are very very different and
and companies are suffering that way
many many of they actually don't make it
through the to the second year
so usually maybe they have this amazing
idea they go through a seed round and
they are not able to take it to the
market
and oh well you can I will pass the mic
from the shoe show yep
yes and basically there is this
knowledge that cannot beat up in order
to solve big problems mainly because we
don't have the tools to make it happen
so that's what we recognized that there
was this really big pool of knowledge
about how to implement the technology
biology as a technology and there's
really big communities I understand how
to do that very accurately but then
there is all of this knowledge that has
to do to actually scale that translate
that knowledge to a product and make it
to actually have a real impact so
there's a lot of new tools that you have
to acquire really fast in order for your
venture to be successful all right so I
got where you were at with grandfather
and that being a crucial part of
learning how to manufacture yeast and
then
to see these bigger facilities and being
like why can't this be done in smaller
facilities and also the dream is to make
this very plug-and-play and very small
manufacturing of whatever biomolecules
you you want and okay so the
technologies micro fluidics and robotics
I want to talk about that as well so
let's let's go with a little just a
little bit more on where was the where
was the moment for you when you were in
Argentina in these in figuring out how
did you bring the cost down 50 X so the
the the footprint the size down 50 X yes
we basically we achieved that by
reducing the size of the facility and
basically integrating technologies that
were off the shelf so it was an
integration of available technologies
and trying to come up with a dynamic of
work that would allow us to make it more
efficient right but we saw that that was
is that wasn't enough we needed to
develop novel technologies that would
integrate the new will solve this
problem by the route so something that
was always really anti intuitive for me
it's the way that we control cell
behavior in within bio reactors so we
have these propellers and it's tool
Extremadura flow to enable the gas
exchange and the masses change required
for the cells to to metabolize and to
deliver the power that we wanted them to
but as I told you for I was studying
agriculture engineering and I was
particularly studying how micron isms
interact with plants and you can find
that within the building plants there's
plenty of bacteria there living within
the phloem some serums of plants and
that growth and that interaction and
delivery of molecules happens in laminar
flow and it was really interesting
because I am in ER yeah and what is that
so it's a it's a regime of
liquid fluid yeah that is really slow
velocities and you have this these
vectors of velocities of the flow that
are really predictable and it moves
microfluidics yes so if you can have a
predictable sort of flow yes and that
can make processes much easier and more
predictable and more tunable so the main
challenge it was how we can scale micro
environment that is has is so highly
controlled and it's known for being
useful for example in eleven achieves on
organs on a chip
so really small devices that allow you
to create the conditions to make studies
but we saw an opportunity in that
technology to be used for bio
manufacturing in the industry and the
first thing that we saw is that we
needed to find a way to scale those
micro channels in a way that make them
compatible to how the industry requires
plugs to manufacture and interesting so
where did they come where did the
transition come from from the yeast for
brewing to the micro fluidics how did
that happen it happened because we found
a problem that was compelling enough for
us to shift our our direction right when
because there's no micro fluidics for
yeast in for bio reactors there are
yeast that will be in microfluidic
devices but there is no bio
manufacturing process that uses micro
fluidics us the way of growing cells
some manufacturing products okay and
that's where you come in yes that's the
first we because this is a technology
that is trying to solve the problem that
we always wanted to solve we started by
saying there is no suppliers of eastern
India and that's because there are not
proper tools and by doing that we
learned that that was a problem
happen across every industry that used
Micronesians to manufacture molecules so
we see these organisms manufacturing
molecules interesting so that was a
problem that was across all the
industries and you're talking about the
micro fluidics inside of the
microorganism we we are talking about
the micro fluidics that provide the
micro and ism's the environment in Peyer
yeah that is better suited for that
intended reaction to have the reaction
happen yeah okay so then your micro
fluidics help the micro organisms
environment make it have an end process
that you wanted to have which is making
a specific biomolecule and the first one
was yeast that you were making yes work
with bacteria and how much yeast have
you made with this process well in Deena
in with this process it's new because we
we have been working in the bio
processor that's how I call the machine
that unites all these technologies
together for the last 18 months 20
months right it's a long time yeah it
happened so fast but the project saying
yeast in Deena is longer than that we
have provided yeast for viewers for a
long time and we have done tests of
productivity per hour that that's a way
of saying how much product can we get
can we get from the from a volume size
of a bioreactor every hour right so
that's how you measure productivity in
viruses and we found that our micro
Berry actors are really efficient in
that way of comparing to other
technology and doing in the bio we work
with e.coli we work with cho cells and
we measure unprecedented increases in
brock duty that goes from 70 x to 100 x
of increase in productivity per hour so
how much is growing in the bioreactor
per hour so now we're working with a
units the heart tell me
leaders and so you get for example for
bacteria you get ten milliliters every
hour but the content of protein or the
country of the aim product is
considerably higher as well so we have
found around 3x in titers of the protein
that's the concentration of the
prompting in over the volume and then
the throughput that we can achieve is I
Rick we are changing the whole volume of
a very actor every hour and that in
current technologies it would be around
24 hours 72 hours in some cases 14 days
so that's a part of the of the benefit
of being able to know word every cell is
going to be at every time so in that way
you can you can correct the mic
environment as the cell requires okay
okay so then the micro environment is
has micro fluidics and you the in and
what are the variables that you change
in the micro environment the temperature
what are these variables
alright so main tree would be the
availability of gas molecules and video
feed right for the four microns me to
metabolize okay so but so gas and feed
and then is gas pressure is that what
that is or what do you mean yes yeah
it's like this all resolved gases is
like dissolved oxygen Oh in the media so
you're you're you're changing the
composition of the gases inside of where
the cell is sent and then the other one
is you're changing the feed that the
cell is getting yeah they are the
concentration of feed available
surrounding the cell and we can do that
really accurately then by doing that you
can also control temperature and control
pH because as you have
gas phase that is interacting with this
cell with a microbe and then you are
adding also liquid lights the media you
have means to control the temperature
and control the pH as the cell
transformed the environment right as
they are metabolizing that media they
are producing heat they are changing the
pH also then you need interesting so the
the microorganism in them is causing the
micro environment to change over time
and then you have to adjust the micro
environment yes and that's how you can
get a continuous production of your
desired biomolecule yes we can this is
what we call cool flow yeah it's cool
right because you keep you keep them
microorganism in flow of the desired
problem yes we we call it cool flow
because it is cool while we're done and
because it is Cu L which is continuous
unidirectional and laminar flow ah got
it
so to put it in TCG well cool foe that
flow continuous unit the you know
unidirectional directional line of
laminar flow that's cool yeah that is
yeah and that is actually very good a
very good thing to remind to understand
it yeah - you see reaction is laminar
but that's a good acronym yeah it is
yeah it is yeah we were doing we thought
about saying the Luke the Luc I think
who who is this look cool no yeah no one
is named Luke in the company so it
doesn't make it let's go with cool no
but if you compare it to the traditional
way scaling up and grow in
microorganisms which is to real and flow
right - bioreactors think about the
traditional bioreactor it is like like
xuxa said in the in the presentation
right in the malay is we are putting
these precious microorganisms these
factories inside a blender
at a blender we prepare the solvent so
try to imagine being a cell yeah trying
to find food trying to breathe yeah and
and you are going through sheer forces
in this system that we developed and
there's no such thing so it's actually
like many we said many many times is a
spa for this yeah
it enables them to relax and do the one
process that you want their treaty very
very well it's there they have food
availability at all times so this is
this is this bar for self-healing of
that is what happens when you in design
around the cell instead of putting the
cell into other cell and trying to
control what happens
so the exercise that we went through is
that exactly how it's like to be a cell
within bioreactor yeah and how can we
prove that how come we provide more
tools for the users also because
sometimes you need cells to divide and
then sometimes you need them to work
then you need them to manufacture
proteins yes so you communicate that
yeah in different ways and you can you
get can you get the environment to
enable the cell to only divider to only
manufacture proteins can you can you get
it to do yes one of those processes we
have the we have the capabilities of
interacting in different stages as we
know he said you need erection so that's
important because that means that if the
cells here now eventually is going to be
in our place and you can know what's
going to happen so basically you can
design a process to say I want this cell
to divide for this amount of time that
is going to be the time that are going
to take that cell to go from here to
here and then when it has arrived here I
don't want them
to divide anymore I want to induce the
synthesis of protein and I want to
induce that synthesis for this amount of
time
Oh interesting because then you can
dynamically change the microenvironment
yes for the cell oh that's great that's
great so now what in terms of in terms
of sizing ideally down the line yes very
very small where is it at right now like
the size of a table Oh where's that so
we we did a presentation demo day today
and we presented one of the modules that
we're using our micro Vario actors they
has an equivalent throughput to a 1
liter very actor in Toulon flow so there
are this ice maybe I can send you the
picture and you can show you the afters
but in that's a around now we are in
100x of smaller sizes and when it comes
to the size of the bioreactor like this
do you guys have it on here in the in
the website now we haven't dated yet it
is not yet on the website because of the
IP strategy that we were needing like to
two or three weeks ago but we're gonna
get it and so this you say a micro
bioreactor so then the strategy then
live a couple thoughts the strategy then
is to get that to as many people that
want to make their own biomolecules as
possible and then have them make what
they want what are you seeing that
people want to make with them like
what's the number one or number two
yeah so I think that there are are real
and CCD in the industry for tools I'll
allow companies to have more predictable
manufacturing facilities and cheaper
ones also lower cost because now that's
prohibit allow them it doesn't allow
them to to get there to get to the
people to the market um but when we say
mic we say micro very act
because they control the
microenvironment not because they are
small right so that's so even there are
some ultra stay they have this
repeatability of the micro environment
that is something that you cannot ask
for a traditional reactor on turbulent
flow as you scale every time you use
larger vessels you have to retune the
the process in order to correct for that
changes of the design and the physical
behavior happen within the bioreactor
well we say micro bio reactors is
because that micro environment it can be
always the same regardless you are
working a 1 liter very micro reactor
10,000 liter micro reactor so that's the
the key breakthrough here is that if
someone has developed a process let's
say now really a really big corporation
has developer assess you know 10,000
litre micro reactor someone can
replicate that process in a 100
milliliter scale and yeah generally
trying to achieve the same resource and
that will happen so because so them so
again micro bioreactor means the climate
that you're controlling inside the
environment the environment in
controlling inside so that way if you're
doing 100 microliters all about 10,000
liters that you can control the
environments that the the microorganisms
are growing inside of interesting so
that's how it can be replicated at up
these scales and enough to ace so are
you say are you how are you so then how
would you get a you know how would your
micro bioreactor a you know how would it
attach onto it you know a 10,000 liter 1
vs. 100 we would you sell the whole 100
micro liter one would you sell just an
attachment for the big one you know how
it yeah and I think that that's the one
of the challenge the we we need to solve
in the near future to understand really
how customers are
are willing to acquire this value that
we are generating right so we have
plenty of conversation with customers
that they understand because they have
to release new molecules to a market and
they know that for every molecule that
they have to release they have to build
an entire new facility so this is
solving up oh wow we quotient in for big
companies when you put it that way it
sounds like a nightmare that to make a
new footprint of manufacturing equipment
every single time they want to make a
new mark that's stupid yeah but on the
other hand there is this opportunity of
this is a bio manufacturing technology
that has been always confined to really
particular specific places in the world
right and that's because mainly because
of the infrastructure that is required
to go through this kind of manufacturing
process if we can create a technology
that behaves equally in high volumes low
volumes all of the sudden there is a
venue of innovation from highly trained
and skilled groups that can develop
knowledge and can develop technology but
can now be implemented in addition to
last manner without massive
manufacturing facilities so now you can
ship this to the places and it's still
the developing world where they can make
whatever biomolecules they need ok so
which one's did we say are the most
commonly used that you think are going
to be most commonly used of biomolecules
what made yeah in the beginning every
technology is new and can I it will be
acquired for people that has really
specific needs for formal functioning
high value and low scale molecules for
example that's where we see the first
option and then there are other places
when we see that there's problems when
it comes to Maya manufacturing and for
example this can sound controversial but
the
one of the big constrain to ring novelty
novel uses of biology to the industry it
is by manufacturing and it's also the
fact that the people that has the
infrastructure to implement it don't
know anything about bio manufacturing
let's say a farm a farm that every year
they use is by stimulants to increase
the crops they know how to use the
product they understand the value in the
product but they don't have the
facilities to manufacture the product
yes so let's say that instead of having
one big company's manufacturing all the
by stimulants in the world they can sell
the information that is required to
manufacture a product on sidewalk Korea
and so that today what happened because
the people that would be in charge on
manufacturing that product they don't
have neither the tools needed skills or
the training to it but if we absorbed up
complexity and we put it inside machine
that can they can read that information
that language of manufacturing and
replicated in is the right way that's
really convenient for all the parties
involved because the the company the
company has to develop the product that
you had to endure with the complexities
and the logistics of manufacturing
abroad for the entire world but they
will get paid for the knowledge that
they have created and on the other hand
the consumer it's like a marketplace
yeah for the knowledge of how you turn a
microorganism into a specific
biomolecule produce the biomolecule yes
so then that marketplace people can just
go and download that information
uploaded into the stem system okay and
by doing that you are multiplying the
amount of people that are that are
actually thinking about using biology or
using biomolecules to solve problems
right because that's something for me
that is central of the conversation if
more people know about the capresso
technology and how it works they can see
it as a way of solving problems in
nearby and that is only so far as being
only
I don't know how to say but it's only
been possible for a really small group
of people that has has the privilege of
being working one of these facilities
yeah
so by putting this technology in more
people Minds not only in their hands we
see a ripple effect of how we interact
with biology as a way to solving real
day problems and I think that's really
powerful and yeah they're getting in the
hands of more people and also making a
process that can you you're building the
future of the process you're not just
making one tiny addition you're
completely changing the way that we do
this process in a more efficient way I
love I love that okay there's probably
something else that's important to touch
here that I think that you guys can
explain what does the what is it what is
the recombinant protein monoclonal what
does that mean and how does that what
does that have to do with the is it does
that have to do the process of
microorganism making the biomolecule yes
in its different ways in which we use
micro Neeson's to manufacture from a
suitable products for treatment right so
then so you have this tier that has to
do with molecules particularly and then
other that has to do with cells right we
are we use the mechanisms to build more
micro and isms that has the same
capabilities that could be seen for
example in clean meat industry in stem
cells industry in yeast
for example we didn't use the yeast to
manufacture molecule because we didn't
do beer if no we will use that yeast to
my factory alcohol but what we sell it
was a number of cells so our process was
to take
yourself really few number of cells and
take it to a large number of cells that
would provide a service for the river
that is actually transforming their malt
into beer so we you can what I'm trying
to say here is that the value of these
mechanisms can be tied to the function
that they provide as a micronation or to
the molecule that they manufacture as a
pract
mm-hmm that make sense I think a little
bit yeah I'm trying to follow it's like
at times is so hard on here when I'm not
you know able to fully grasp everything
you're multiplying workers is that you
have you have one working that
transforms sugar into alcohol but you
need a lot of them in order to make a
lot of beer so then you use
biomanufacturing
to increase the number of cells that
will eventually transform or not into
alcohol yes on the other cases you have
functional molecules there are proteins
mainly that can target a specific cell
or block a compound that is bad for you
so basically what you use by
manufacturing to tell to to tell us the
cells and the Micronesians
to manufacture that protein and then
afterwards you separate micron isms of
the protein and you purify that protein
and that's the end product that ends up
going to the market okay okay and then
what does this look like in application
in the pharmaceutical industry or an
agriculture what did the applications
look like we talked about it a little
bit but give us some more
all right so or anything that goes from
medicines these are the insulin is made
this way for example and vaccines
treatment for stem cells they
personalized medicines were they going
to need yourselves this is all made this
way this all everything is using these
tools yes using it was
yeah and so if we if we need yourselves
to treat you we need a set of tools that
are meant for the dosage that you
require is called molecular
manufacturing is that what kind of the
yeah yes
yeah like the insulin and yeah so this
is also this also opens a new world of
possibilities in terms of business
because when it comes to be like huge
demands for a product so there is a
no-brainer which is no problem we go
through with building $10,000,000
facility so because the demand it allows
it right it makes it profitable but when
you come like you are saying with very
small and specific demands there is not
not a possibility but when you can build
your own biotech facility for a small
fraction of the money you would use do
to build a traditional acidity and that
new facility it fits inside of a regular
office yeah then the sky's the limit
right yeah and I want I won't
manufacture my own insulin probably I
would let the main big dawgs
manufacturer right because they have
much larger you already know they are
install they have other advantages as
you know no she sticks with relations
but I'm going back to personalized
medicine for example a I I believe that
would be really important for hospitals
to have tools that would allow them to
treat patients directly right and that's
the leveraging this technology and bio
manufacturing I mean and if we can be
part of that that would be amazing but
today that that won't happen because the
the logistic require
a sample from you and take it to
industry facility I can manage it that
way it makes it too tedious or too
expensive so basically they end up
result is that we know how to cure you
but it's expensive right you have to be
able to afford it so and that's that's
not something that that's something that
we can see today with novel therapies
basically expensive because of the
Hutton the skilled labor that they are
required and the facilities to make a
new facility for the new treatment the
new personalized medicine rather than be
able to just compute the environment
that it needs in order to make the
treatment is that right yes it's like
once you once you have an understanding
how to how you do it you can replicate
in a centralized manner so there's
always be this part of you developing
the approach the process and
understanding how it works but
eventually they may be different is how
you create impact out of that knowledge
if you have to explain it to each person
and to each country that you're working
with how you have to do it or you have
to explain it to a machine right and you
know how to talk to that machine because
you have created that language and how a
good process looks like to a machine and
then an egg what is the agriculture yes
so we increasingly are using more micron
isms to control the environment that
says that plants experience and we use
migrants model to promote growth yeah
and to provide capabilities to sustain
growth conditions yeah so um and that's
only going to get more demand yes and
more knowledge intensity various so yeah
and there's other things as this out of
biological value in Arctic because there
is where you have the plants that's
where you have the the animals today so
there is a a path to follow that is to
rebuild the whole industry with with new
and more efficient technologies the
other side will be to leverage the
current infrastructure in Arctic and to
provide tools that will enable these
high-value technologies for salvage
manufactures always meet for example to
be performed in by the infrastructure is
currently there and there's a lot of
value in that because yeah you have
local farmers I have a history with
their cattle and history about
interacting with environment that they
live in and the sort of knowledge I'm to
my opinion really valuable knowledge and
identity linked to the rural way of
living that could be preserved if we
have tools that enable them to be part
of the transition towards a more
sufficient technology right so that's
part of also is the I want to I want to
clarify this because I think this is
important is the when you have the
different examples of either me
purchasing the the the actual micro
bioreactor from you or you adding the
micro bioreactor onto an existing
bioreactor infrastructure so you will do
both or do you think which one do you
think you'll start with yeah the
question we are we are having we are
interacting with clients and customers
and potential partners to basically to
hear how they would use this technology
what we have found out is that even for
weak companies building facilities is a
problem so that's something that we
didn't you if we're coming to San
Francisco we thought that because of the
high prices of some products that's not
so important the manufacturing there is
this we lift up manufacturing doesn't
add value but actually adds a lot of
constraint to the business model because
someone could say it is already cheap my
thing is not cheap because you have to
wait for years to build that
manufacturing plant one that is build is
there to stay and now that you can you
can shift your there you did all the
relations so you have to commit to that
yeah and so maybe someone would say that
like there's no this is not that
expensive but it is expensive for the
decision making of a pharmaceutical
companies and biotech companies in
general and now you can't afford to be
to have a narrower scope of decision
making because the game is changing
every year new technologies are coming
and you that's where we believe that
it's important to have a technology that
is also dynamic totally what is the most
common gas that is being added is it
oxygen carbon what's the yes mainly
oxygen nitrogen co2 oxygen nitrogen CO
and so then they do you have then to
have compressed oxygen nitrogen co2 to
be able to add to the environment over
time yeah we were we really low
pressures one of the good thing our
systems that we have a lot of surface of
contact between the liquid and gas me
face so we can provide a really good
exchange of gas into the media we are
working with high pressures
that is something that doesn't happen in
the car industry we have lots of
pressure building up inside of our
reactor
you have really high shear forces as a
side product of the propeller going
3,000 rpms and um you have a community
of cells there are untraceable and
that's a problem because you have a
community that you know how long have to
be in there if you are we are continuous
or semi continuous approach some cells
will leave the system but there are
others that will stay inside and you
know how long a cell has been there and
that is detrimental for the production
so having a unidirectional path allow
you to know the life the work life of
that cell and when do you want that
cells to go out from the system so even
if there's a lot of work to be done in
that area that kind of capability is
something that today you cannot control
there's no trace of cells so being able
to do that opens up a world of new
possibilities when it comes to
biomanufacturing you know how to create
new ways of using cells to manufacture
products yep this is so amazingly it's
very it's very unique I love it I love
it and yeah and it's good because like I
was saying earlier it's not just an
addition this is a completely new way of
thinking about things with micro
fluidics robotics is very interesting is
there something that we didn't cover
that we should mention and that we want
to our technology to be used
we truly believe that that is a really
need for this and we would like also to
hear what someone that could be looking
at this might think about our approach
we were open for every insight and
applications or improvement we
approached this problem
willing to solve it so we can use all
the help lines available and we are
opening this conversation it's not like
are you staying in the San Francisco Bay
Area yeah yeah good good
yeah we just opened an operation here in
San Francisco in the Bay Area and
although we have our alpha test told
booked up after demo a so many startups
approached us that we are considering
open it up again and maybe doing a
larger alpha testing so yeah everyone
watching just we are super approached
all with this you can shoot us an email
and we'll be in touch yeah awesome so
that was that was very good so we have a
lot to learn about the way that we can
manufacture specific molecules and
actually really its tap into the the
verge of changing the variables in the
environment so that we can optimize the
production this is brilliant I love it
good job guys
thank you thank you very much thanks for
thanks for joining us on the show that
was a lot of fun and it was really fun
to learn about that everyone that was
watching definitely check them out stem
dot buy OST AMD i/o links in the bio
also give the comment below let us know
your thoughts about the about the
process and also about ways that you
think it can maybe be augmented over
time thanks everyone for tuning in and
we'll see you soon peace
[Music]